Eravamo rimasti ragazzi che ero nella
mia camera che non è questa in realtà
sono entrati Un'altra cosa volevo fare
la intro nello stesso punto dove avevo
smesso l'ultima volta ma non non trovo
più la mia camera il che potrebbe essere
un problema quando vado a dormire
stanotte perché dormivano nel letto di
qualcuno ha serratura a livello 2 ah
posso sbloccare tipo Skyrim vado a
scassinare le cose posso rubarti la cosa
Vabbè comunque Ragazzi allora ehm c'è
una cosa che vorrei dirvi ehm sto
testando un nuovo tipo di Gameplay Nel
senso che visto che questo gioco mi
piace Secondo me è meglio che non tagli
niente facciamo direttamente una ripresa
unica e vediamo cosa succede skippate
voi su una parte vi annoia a sto punto
perché visto che mi piace a questo punto
me lo gioco tutto se volete godervi
l'esperienza Esattamente come la godo io
rispetto al primo video ehm ci saranno
forse meno tagli non so se non taglierò
proprio niente o quasi quasi mi fa
piacere Allora questa è la madonna
Sembra la testa di
chi è Ignazia Wild Smith sembrava la
testa quella di Art Attack Ragazzi sto
male Beh il capo Vabbè comunque a parte
questo
ho scoperto Allora ho giocato eh 5
minuti ma solo perché volevo prepararmi
la mattina a livello scoperto che esiste
la polvere volante quindi c'è la polvere
volante per viaggiare attraverso i
luoghi di Hogwarts ma anche fuori
Hogwarts perché se noi usciamo Com'è che
ho fatto prima prima ho schiacciato un
tasto che non so come a mappa generale
forse
No così fa uscire vi giuro ve lo giuro
Prima l'ho fatto ve lo giuro non so come
ho fatto però prima si vedeva tutta la
mappa di di Harry Potter che anche oltre
Hogwarts Eccola non so non so come ho
fatto raga
È gigantesco e ci crede Allora Hogwarts
è qua Ok questa è Hogwarts per darvi un
attimo l'idea di come funziona
e poi c'è tutta Guarda quanta roba
sto male Quanto è grande Vabbè vabbè
giocate voi c'è qualche roba Guarda
quanto è grosso sto mondo cioè ragazzi
voi potete andare ovunque questa cosa è
pazzesca questa cosa qua anche qua tipo
qui Chissà che cacchio c'è ragazzi
veramente non vedo l'ora poi quando
abbia quando avremo la scopa potremmo
andare ad esplorare in giro che adesso
Purtroppo non me la sono ancora
sbloccata Vabbè Questa era per darvi
un'idea E se voi cliccate su ehm come
l'ho fatto No Se voi andate su la mappa
di Hogwarts e schiacciate su un luogo in
particolare tipo adesso io devo andare a
difesa controllare più scure che la mia
prima lezione perché ce n'è uno che lo
sblocca Eccolo qua perfetto quando c'è
il focolare verde vuol dire che ho
sbloccato il luogo quindi andiamo
direttamente lì e da qua poi ci avviamo
verso difesa credo che per sbloccare i
focolari ci devi passare prima davanti
giustamente perché sennò uno va ovunque
senza che ha sporcato niente quindi
siamo nella sala centrale molto bella
Ragazzi andiamo subito però non l'ho
segnata dov'è
questa lezione di alla lezione di
incantesimius entrambi facciamo difesa
contro l'artistico Dai dai che la mia
materia preferita e invece a scuola
avevo solo
matematica Porca Vabbè lasciamo
stare Andiamo avanti Apriti per favore
porta gigante
ma è magia Questa è magia e non fate
domande e magia ci saranno delle patch
che risolveranno queste cose Ragazzi
tranquilli Oh ci sta che ci siano sti
problemi ogni tanto l'importante è che
il gioco sia figo
non so come arrivare là sopra perché
sono ad Hogwarts per la prima volta
nella mia vita cos'è questo
ma ci posso fare qualcosa per illuminato
prima Madonna ragazzi ci sono alcuni
momenti in cui il personaggio mi
somiglia veramente tantissimo Cioè tipo
quando lo vedo di profilo alle volte è
incredibile
Allora prova a entrare qua dentro Non so
bene Effettivamente Madonna quanto è
grosso sto coso non so bene come
arrivare in vari luoghi perché non ci
sono ancora stato capito Quindi è un po'
un po' così Però vediamo allora Let's go
poi pian piano dovrò eh cioè imparerò
come è fatta ho guardato che ansia Salve
che sono le telecamere no telecamera no
no no no
Hai rotto il cazzo questa è difeso la
riconoscono
ma ho combattuto contro cavalieri di
pietra di Cristo Quindi se volete faccio
io ragazzi
Ma cosa fare qua deve cadere in tutti
tutti gli anni di tutti i film di Mario
scolastico
unico
Del 1878 lo conoscete
Harry Potter
di Bracconieri del Galles
non ha fatto una sega in tutto tutta la
sua vita ma se ne vanta
sono spoiler di Harry Potter questi ma
faccio finta che voi avete visti tutti
questo lo dico con i vecchi
ricordi
[Musica]
mettiamo la prova ciò che abbiamo
imparato partendo da zero
Sì io non parto da zero zia io ho fatto
fuori già il demonio in persona nel
primo nella prima missione Cioè io
veramente sono già skillato non dovrei
essere codore insegnare io a voi però fa
niente
Lorenzo Ostuni Leviosa
mi fa sempre dire leggere il mio nome
inizio gioco Non so perché mi fa troppo
effetto
ora
provo qualcosa di più grosso
no sto scherzando ragazzi una battuta ok
È una battuta
questo ma me lo fai fare a me A parte la
cinematica lo voglio fare io
Grazie prof
Minchia ragazzi sono corvonero non mi
abituerò mai a sta cosa assurda vedermi
costa tunica iniziamo dall'incantesimo
base e come si va
alla base Sì ok
visto il manichino
E come lo lancio
Ho capito ma se non mi dici come cosa
devo schiacciare Ah ok Ho capito
ok Quindi io posso assegnare gli
incantesimi ai vari tasti Ok ho capito
bene
[Musica]
ma il modo migliore per fare pratica il
duello iniziamo con voi Va benissimo
[Musica]
va bene
ce ne avrei un sacco di altri cartesimi
ad esempio
ma vado a che età dovrebbero questo non
si può ancora fare che non l'ho
sbloccato Sebastian School a nord sono
caduto giusto
Grazie Grazie prof Maurizio non è vero
[Musica]
alla prossima io vedo sulla mini mappa
che ci sono i forzieri no lo vedo anche
qua però non ho ben capito come
Perché mi dice che in alto prima della
classe bello un trofeo che non avevo mai
guadagnato in vita mia mi dice Io vedo i
trofei sulla mini mappa di continuo però
non so come raggiungerli perché vedo che
in questo caso è in armatura Ma quanta
roba c'è
molto male Vabbè a caso ho rubato una
tazzina Arrivederci
dico Vedo roba sulla mia mappa ma non
conosco tipo questa qua è una polvere
volante Però come la sblocco
no la facciamo sta cosa ragazzi perché
sennò veramente faccio solo robe
canoniche e non capisco bene come
funziona tipo Ecco qua c'è una polvere
volante Perfetto Quindi vado qua e la
dovrei sbloccare Perfetto
Ok abbiamo capito come sbloccare la cosa
la polvere volante cioè le destinazioni
della polvere volante quindi questo è
già è già molto buono perché possiamo
spostarci in varie zone più velocemente
qua devo andare ma questa è incantesimi
incantesimi tutto sto casino senza
volerlo Però vabbè
ok Qua Vabbè facciamo anche lezione di
tanto siamo qua Vamos a lezione So bene
che
che lezione sia però cioè incantesimo
che lezione dobbiamo fare ma ci sono
sempre gli stessi i miei compagni sono
sempre gli stessi No perché ad Hogwarts
non è come a scuola in Italia ti scrive
i corsi trovi i compagni diversi in base
al corso
Grazie grazie
[Musica]
hai già conosciuto il professor Roma no
possiamo iniziare
il cappello
sarà un anno fondamentale per la vostra
formazione in questa arte magica Ma io
che dico che mi ha chiesto se Dominick
per una simile sfida Bene ragazzi adesso
Aprite i vostri libri alla pagina 517 ma
prima di iniziare qualcuno di voi sa
qual è la differenza tra le formule
dell'incantesimo cambia colore è quello
di crescita Sì prof di crescita lo puoi
usare anche proprio nessuno
si poteva dire sta cosa Peccato Temo
proprio che ora sia un po' troppo tardi
per studiare
[Musica]
sapete fare un incantesimo
Beh vedo che sarà successo soprattutto
trovatevi un compagno e prendete
posizione ai lati opposti
Vieni con me che facciamo l'incantesimo
di appello
e a turno eseguite un'evocazione per
toglierli di mano all'altro basterà un
libro per ogni coppia di studenti
signorina Day Grazie torna a posto Ora
[Musica]
Accio Ah ma tutto sto casino per Accio
mandate una Cioè dai tutto
sto bordello per insegnarmi Accio Ma dai
Vi chiedo non avevo capito forse quello
impari davvero Non avevo capito fosse
quello non capirlo e vedo del potenziale
Ma ricorda
non serve senza allenamento
[Musica]
da qualche ora vorrei lezioni così ad
Hogwarts invece starei volentieri delle
ore però per goderci una bella boccata
d'aria fresca Seguitemi
cioè noi col prof dobbiamo andare in
giro a fare l'escursioni cioè invece di
stare in classe a studiare Invece le
elezioni ad Hogwarts che dovrebbero
durare ore talmente sono belle durano un
minuto e quelle a scuola normale durano
sei anni ritengo giusto giusto siano
aspetti complementari qualsiasi
giocatore di qui dice sarebbe Concorde
niente
per esercitarsi con l'incantesimo di
appello vero
[Musica]
Ma che cacchio sta facendo Raga io non
sto in porta non sono capace
Premium C'è comunque per essere al
quinto anno immaginate di iniziare il
quinta liceo senza aver fatto tutti gli
altri anni per il progetto semplice
Lancia a la faccio io su una delle sfere
poi arresta l'incantesimo quando la
sfera eh
come si arresta Non ho idea di come si
arresti cosa devo schiacciare Ecco così
Allora
Come on baby e non sapevo come
arrestarlo raga adesso lo so non vale
[Musica]
50 punti
competizione signore che palle Ti va di
fare gli onori di casa direi che cos'è
Grifondoro notazzo rosso cos'è non l'ho
vista
non sarà il blu Ah dobbiamo scontrarci
Ok ok adesso Ok ci sta ci sta ci sta Va
bene adesso sì adesso le faccio un culo
quadro perché adesso ho capito come si
gioca prego faccia a lei poi è bello che
non sono fermo posso fare quello che
voglio posso andare in giro È bellissimo
sta roba
Ma fai schifo Ah però devo stare attento
a non non far collidere le palle cioè io
posso buttare giù anche la sua No cioè
ti posso fare così
[Musica]
No sono stupido
Sono idiota Scusa no
Cacchio adesso si sentirà una
incredibile però adesso io faccio un
colpo alla maestra e facevo anche a Wii
sport bowling Aspetta eh Aspetta non te
no aspetta eh che qua faccio le cose
guarda Eh mo aspetta
come non è caduto niente
co del demonio Ok allora qua mi devo
impegnare tantissimo raga è
difficilissimo che io vinca sta gara ma
ci devo provare ce la posso fare allora
L'unico modo è buttare giù questa qua
Ciao ciao
Who is the Champions
però il resto si poteva dire
insomma L'importante è vincere io a
bocce me la cavo ma sarà l'età che è
successo pure
l'Inter
comunque Ragazzi è fighissimo sto gioco
Ma vai prima tu vado prima io Vai prima
tu muoviti
sono fortissimi questi Oh aspetta che
devo ti togli dalle palle che devo
vincere Grazie
No non quello Ok Perfetto Ciao
botta è troppo poco potenti
è colpa mia ragazzi perché se tengo
premuto va più forte ma se non sono
stupido io
Ok
allora Io punterei a questa a sto punto
tanto l'importante è buttarli giù le
palle Chi inizia per prima e
svantaggiatissima sto gioco Comunque
ragazzi
ho sbagliato il tempismo invece è giusto
Figurati
Va beh
Cioè non sono il campione di sto gioco
ma comunque
se mi impegno posso cavarmela Ah che
scarsa
Eh vabbè fai schifo proprio
cioè qua Basta che faccio anche solo 10
raga teoricamente
Ciao
orto muso
vince il campo dell'evocatore ragazzi se
io sono forte non ci potevo fare niente
500 punti a coronavirus
ho fatto io non so se è chiaro
entra legalizzato
ricordate di prendere le vostre cose
bella partita
devo ammettere che avevo sottovalutato
il tuo talento ci ho messo settimane per
imparare bene Accio
dopo un po' diventa più facile te lo
assicuro
[Musica]
Sono felice che tu capisca
così mi consoli sono molte le cose a cui
devo abituarmi Altroché mi fa strano
raga che c'è la voce un po' robotica
perché l'ho pucciata apposta per farla
somigliare alla mia però un po' robotico
è stata offerta la cattedra di
divinazione così abbiamo lasciato
l'uganda per venire dall'altra parte del
mondo in una nuova scuola un nuovo paese
e invece sono ancora a Milano
Posso andare via grazie È stato un
piacere parlare
con te
altrettanto Arrivederci
voglia parlarti meglio non farlo
aspettare a me ci si vede in giro
vorrebbe darmi ad esempio che ne so 150
punti
Voleva parlarmi il professore Sì
immagino che la prima lezione di
incantesimi ti sia piaciuta molto bella
proprio la lezione sarebbe stata una
gara all'aperto signore che gusto c'è
nel fare ciò che è previsto Complimenti
è un avversaria tenace Anche se mi
sembra un po' distratta Ultimamente
la professoressa Weasley ha chiesto ai
professori di fornirti alcuni
insegnamenti al di fuori del curriculum
ordinario resto ti contatterò per
assegnarti un compito speciale Ok i
compiti extra va bene
Guarda Hogwarts sarebbe l'unico posto
dove mi andrebbe a fare di fare compiti
extra effettivamente mi andrebbe anche
bene posso andare di suo a vedere cosa
c'è
cioè
si può andare ovunque si può andare
ovunque Questo gioco incredibile
pazzesco solo che non posso sbloccare
perché non ho ancora sbloccato Halo mora
che Immagino sarà la prossima
la prossima il prossimo incantesimo la
da sbloccare però l'incantesimo di
appello
Chissà
nella mia vita però devo alzarmi a
prendere il telecomando Come sta andando
il primo giorno bene Samantha non so chi
tu sia però va bene ciao Perché la gente
mi parla Cioè è una cosa che non succede
nella vita reale
nocerno te la cavi bene con incantesimi
sei gentile a dirlo non è stata
Nazionale difficile ho avuto la fortuna
l'ho preso a pesci in faccia umile e di
fidarti delle tue capacità ma lui tende
a fidarsi troppo delle sue vanes Sarà
meglio che finisca i compiti Io non
posso contare sulla fortuna dei
principianti col professorone
Arrivederci Samantha Allora abbiamo
conosciuto un sacco di persone già
Comunque ragazzi pazzesco sono diventato
amico con tutta Madonna mi sento parte
di Io sto gioco incredibile ti dà la
sensazione di far parte di Hogwarts Cioè
mi sento di conoscere la gente quando
vado in giro
di di andare
sciarpa di lana scura quindi posso
equipaggio Aspetta aspetta che
l'equipaggiamento ancora non l'ho fatto
che senso
perché voi non lo sapete ma non lo so
neanche io che teoricamente qua potrei
possiamo assegnare cose che ci aumentano
il danno le cose addirittura addirittura
[Musica]
quello che ho trovato io questo ho
trovato è una sciarparara quindi è blu
Ottimo ottimo Ottimo ottimo
ho trovato una sciarpa blu raga pazzesco
voi potete metterla e a quanto ne so se
non ci piace un qualcosa
nell'equipaggiamento cioè proprio come
il look intendo Si può cambiare il look
pur tenendo le statistiche questa cosa
non so come si faccia ma Vabbè chi se ne
frega Comunque avevi modifica aspetto
scritto qua modifica aspetto perché
Quindi uno può decidere di non farla
vedere ma comunque ti rimane oppure di
farla vedere o cambiare semplicemente
l'aspetto quella originale che era
questa qua va benissimo
vado in giro con la sciarpa anche se ci
sono 27.000 gradi Comunque si trovano
gli oggetti in giro gli oggetti di
potenziano Quindi sei più forte questa
cosa qua è boh È incredibile stavo
dicendo comunque che mi dà proprio
che mi dà proprio la sensazione di
essere ad Hogwarts Di
conoscere il posto di andare in giro
incontra gente che conosco perché
comunque quando noi facciamo amicizia
con le persone poi quelli c'è li
troviamo in giro tipo in questo caso
Samantha Vabbè però fighissimo Ha una
del professor stick è questa questa è
Laura del professor questa no questo è
il bagno Allora questo è Dov'è Laura
questa è dove sono adesso e poi tutta
l'aula Ok ma dov'è il professore
professor figo è quello iniziale
professore dove
c'è che mi ha fatto cioè il professore
che mi ha portato a Hogwarts questo non
si apre credo
no si si apre una serratura Devo
sbloccare ragazzi Devo sbloccare
all'omora 100% Se vi ricordate se avete
visto la il gameplay in anteprima che
avevo fatto di Hogwarts Legacy che ha
avuto l'onore di provarlo dopo scuola
con la Weasley andiamo ehm praticamente
io ho
utilizzato incantesimi giocato a parte
di gioco molto avanzate e quindi senza
saper giocare banalmente e quindi ho
visto come fatto alohomora alohomora è
bellissima perché non è che si chiama
che fai alohomora e si apre la serratura
tu devi sbloccarla la serratura in un
modo tipo alla Skyrim ma ancora più
complesso e non lo sapevo fare infatti
perché non avevo fatto la Ecco non lo
sapevo fare perché non avevo fatto la
lezione di incantesimi Quindi vedete che
le lezioni servono perché io non lo
sapevo fare Me lo sono dovuta far
sbloccare in quel video
Se vi ricordate L'avete visto me l'ha
sbloccato un addetto perché io non
riuscivo a farlo Quindi non vedo l'ora
di vederla lì di assistere alla lezione
per poi sapere sbloccare le serrature
tanto per adesso non ho neanche
l'incantesimo
in presenza di cotanta arrogante che
parla Vabbè di voi cosa c'è al serratura
a livello 2 perché poi Immagino che tu
più utilizzi l'incantesimo e più ti
aumenta la skill dell'incantesimo stesso
quindi
cortile di trasfigurazione
qua tra loro un sacco di studenti in
Ermellini Io lo so Ah guarda Si può
accarezzare perché si possono
accarezzare i gatti in questo gioco era
il proprio necessario una risposta è sì
la risposta è sì Era necessario No
aspetta che prendo questo Mannaggia c'è
la polvere volante di fuori porca in
stanza professoressa Pensavo la stessa
cosa tic forse puoi aiutare troviamo un
toc da qualche parte Ti prego
[Musica]
Spero che le prime lezioni siano andate
bene Sì professoressa
ha insegnato diverse cose prima del tuo
arrivo
molte cose che non mi hai detto sul tuo
viaggio di arrivo ancora questa vuole
sapere le cose no professoressa non le
ho detto niente non ho fatto niente
in ogni caso devi continuare a lavorare
su ciò che hai imparato Pertanto ho
chiesto ai colleghi di assegnarti degli
incarichi in più per velocizzare i tuoi
progressi perché i professori mi ha
chiesto di non parlarle di cosa è
successo prima e lei continua a chiedere
ma lui continua a dire non è successo
niente prima di arrivare ad Hogwarts
potrebbe usare la verità serum ma è
vietato sugli studenti il professor bene
Si incontrerà con te fuori per
assegnarti il tuo primo incarico ora a
proposito della visita ofsmid di cui
parlavamo andiamo organizzati per
sostituire i materiali che hai perso
compresi i semi e ricette di pozioni e
magici Grazie professoressa
superiori
Ok vado subito sono davvero impaziente
di visitare il villaggio
stupenda Un sacco di anni prima magari
Sebastian Saloon o in acciaio Nike
è un maledetto
lestofante Natti ottima
centinaia e una studentessa molto
talentuosa e conosce bene la zona e la
mia Hermione Granger
posto meglio evitare lui e i suoi sodali
incluso il suo cosiddetto braccio destro
teofalo
finito con l'incarico del professorone
ne troverai la tua guida all'ingresso
del Castello non c'è tempo da perdere
Prima completi il tuo lavoro e prima
potrai goderti una burrobirra ai tre
manici di scopa Minchia
che figo Ah bellissimo che meno male che
non mi usa il verità serum cioè non usa
verità solo su di me se no le direi
tutto quello che è successo prima mi
piace che gioco io a West Legacy che
sono del mondo di Harry Potter
e non sono uno che lo gioca a calcio
storico stiamo parlando lo so Mi piace
questo mi piacerebbe anche a me quindi
godiamocelo insieme ragazzi Noi mega fan
di Harry Potter questo qua che sta qua
fuori e sta a guardare gli uccelli però
professore La prego
Ecco
voleva insegnarmi un nuovo incantesimo
professore proprio proprio un
incantesimo
l'incantesimo riparatore Io voglio
mostrarvi
un oggetto rotto e riaverlo come nuovo
Potrebbe tornarmi facilmente utile più
spesso di quanto si creda come ti
anticipava la professoressa Weasley non
sarò l'unico a insegnarti incantesimi al
di fuori delle lezioni devi metterti in
pari con gli altri studenti molti dei
tuoi professori hanno consentito a farlo
ma per prima cosa ciascuno ti chiederà
di portare a termine dei compiti
preliminari ne ho alcuni e da svolgere
oggi Portali a termine e poi torna da me
imparerai il riparo In men che non si va
bene Lo rivaluto Comunque lui eh non è
così antipatico come pensavo completerò
subito gli incarichi professoressa
Ah ma tra l'altro Scusatemi ma la Coppa
delle case dove era giusta Chissà dov'è
Io voglio andare allora Scusatemi un
attimo
qua vorrei fare le Allora facciamo così
facciamo questa missione poi vado subito
a vedere prima e finisco il video dove
sono Dov'è la Coppa delle case vado a
fare un attimo esplorazione Ok Ehm
[Musica]
vicino alla statua danneggiato ok
a questa
come cazzo la prendo
ok
[Musica]
devo andare in giro ok Quindi non c'era
solo questa Ok Scusatemi non avevo
capito Volevo
Questo vi fa capire comunque che man
mano che vi insegnano l'incantesimo poi
di padroneggi tutti Quindi l'obiettivo è
proprio andare in giro e saperli usare a
piacimento sta cosa è fighissima questa
Zenobia nok ci parlo dopo perché prima
finisco la la missione e poi
c'era la colonna di mezzo non l'ho preso
l'ho preso l'ho preso
[Musica]
Ah l'ho già preso che è perfetto Finisco
questa raga e vado alla sana grande
voglio assolutamente vedere se c'è la
Coppa delle case e A quanti punti stiamo
i compiti ho completato gli incarichi
professore meraviglioso puoi dire di
sapere gli incantesimi essenziali Grazie
proviamo il Caro vecchio incantesimo
riparatore va bene
ricordatelo
e compiere movimenti decisi Voglio
vedere energia so bacchetta protetta Sì
signore
ricorda la tua bacchetta conduce la tua
magia
la minchia ah perché io pensavo che
Quando impari l'incantesimo pensavo tu
dovessi disegnare la lettera
dell'incantesimo quindi in questo caso
una R Invece no è proprio il movimento
della bacchetta che è diverso quindi il
riparo lo fai facendo un cerchio
ok e si riparano le cose Adesso proviamo
sulla statua qua Se desideri
non so che cosa succede ragazzi sarà
quello tutte ste pagine però questo mi
fa capire che io posso andare in giro e
usare gli incantesimi come mi pare
questa cosa mi fa impazzire bene
l'obiettivo del gioco capito che
insegnarti come vi stavo dicendo prima è
insegnarci a utilizzare incantesimi
piano piano in modo tale che poi voi
siate autosufficienti nell'utilizzarli
in situazioni senza che il gioco ve lo
dica Cioè quindi noi andiamo in giro
Vediamo una situazione utilizziamo che
ne so Accio quindi proprio come se foste
nel mondo di Harry Potter questa cosa è
pazzesca questa cosa è incredibile
ragazzi è incredibile voi non so se
capite le importanza di questo è
pazzesco
o i brividi ve lo giuro Sono veramente
emozionato È incredibile Porca vacca
quanto tempo per avere un gioco così
finalmente cacchio finalmente Vabbè
usciamo voglio andare abbastanza nella
sala grande ma questo perché mi
interessa capire se
c'è la coppa posso viaggiare velocemente
No perché non ho scoperto quella parte
ma ci andiamo subito ne hai fatto me ne
fotto Allora si può mettere il segnalino
almeno
hefgold my friends ancora non ho la
scopa in tutto questo però la scopa
Immagino che arrivi tra Boh non lo so
un'oretta di gioco UNO due rette di
gioco penso sia normale perché sennò
dirà tutto subito E vabbè Salve
sarebbe un labirinto non ci saprei mai
arrivare
Ok Eccoci qua oh yes Come on baby ciao
ciao
ragazzi Sono troppo contento mi tradisci
hai un altro è pieno di Enigmi sto
cacchio di gioco pieno
qua dovrei fare qualcosa non so che cosa
però vabbè lo farò in un secondo momento
me ne fotto
e qua ragazzi eravamo al siamo dove
eravamo al nell'anteprima che vi ho
portato la settimana scorsa due
settimane fa Scusate Brava complimenti e
Let's go vediamo se c'è allora la Coppa
delle case non mi ricordo dove si trovi
esattamente mi pare davanti
alla sala da pranzo Quindi tipo qua
[Musica]
No dov'è entriamo nella sala da pranzo
anzitutto non è questa ma è
Eccola qua Eccola questo stavo Beh vedi
che c'è Tu Madonna che bello a quando ci
stiamo
ancora tutto a poco poco No zero Oh A
stronzi ma siamo a zero noi ma nessuno
ha preso un punto Ma come Ma Facciamo
cagare ragazzi corvonero Svegliatevi
porco del demonio Oh cosa cosa cosa stai
qua per niente
maledizione siamo a zero raga cioè vabbè
letteralmente cioè Vi prego c'è
Grifondoro ne ha un pochettino
tassorosso ne è un po' di più corrono
non ero niente e Serpeverde anche
Serpeverde non ha niente
non
puoi neanche immaginare quanto fosse
scomodo viaggiare prima
tempo
Io invece lo immagino doppia alla metro
allora
Quanto è figo che sto male Guarda che
roba
cos'è Ma cos'è che gioco incredibile
Porco demonio Cos'è sta roba che ogni
tanto vado in giro
Ragazzi sto male Scusatemi
è troppo figo Cosa c'è di qua mi dice
che c'è un forziere di sotto però
secondo me non sono forzieri di sotto
sono forzieri che per sbloccarli devi
fare qualcosa
E vabbè comunque andiamo avanti Volevo
vedere se c'era il cielo di Hogwarts
ma qua devi sbloccare
un enigma devi sbloccare la porta 7
tentacoli 24 Ma che ne so Sarà Devi
metterli qua No è chiaramente lucertola
questo sicuro hai visto che ci ha
azzeccato
Gli enigmi I ragazzi li lasciamo nel
prossimo perché adesso voglio fare solo
un po' di esplorazione perché prima di
finire qua non mi segnala cioè Allora
Scusatemi qua mi segna un forziere lo
vedete qua qua in questo punto qui
preciso non c'è il forziere qua però è
qua
come Cioè non è che l'hanno sbagliato a
metterlo nella Mini mappa e se lo apro
tipo non c'è non è più qui vediamo no
Quindi è proprio c'è un forziere anche
qua che non è segnato cioè che non è che
non si vive non si vede però vabbè Si
vede che quello di sbloccare con
qualcosa tipo l'enigma di prima
ho fatto un Revello solo per capire se
qua intorno C'è qualcosa di strano no
No Cosa c'è di qua
quanta roba esiste in sto posto raga
quanto Non sapevo ci fosse una stanza al
lato della sala da pranzo
Ok
Ah la parte di sopra la sala da pranzo
ok ecco
no
non ce l'ho ancora però hanno insegnato
professore Invece di insegnarmi ste
merde di riparo e mi insegna a
scassinare le cose come i veri studenti
Mi scusi Che palle vabbè
c'è il simbolo degli Illuminati vorrei
dire in basso a destra lo vedete
Però non so cosa cos'è
Cos'è sta roba raga provo a usare
l'humus
Ragazzi ho capito come funzionano le
magie pazzesche cioè io riesco a fare le
cose però non è tipo un collezionabile
Vabbè comunque mi fa impazzire sta cosa
che vado in giro e uso le magie e faccio
le cose questa cosa non ha senso È
pazzesco e non è niente di programmato
ce lo voglio fare veramente io lo faccio
Boh raga sto male
Allora in tutto questo mi servirebbero
anche delle pozioni per le per i
combattimenti eccetera che se ci finisco
poi ovviamente con tutte queste cose le
potrò comprare penso ad hocs Made
comunque diagonale è originale di notte
perché tipo vorrei andare nel reparto
proibito quelle robe là fighissimo me
una figata Salve
Scusate sto andando da Lesley cioè la
tipa di
qui ci sarà anche un Granger da qualche
parte che non c'entra niente con
Hermione solo perché hanno voluto
utilizzare un cognome del film credo
visto che non è Canonico nati non hai
aspettato troppo vero per nulla la
professoressa Weasley mi ha detto che
devi recarti augsmid Immagino tu non
vede l'ora di riavere delle cose tue e
di vedere il villaggio
smartphone Sì va bene andiamo
[Musica]
bellissimo il cortile esterno bellissimo
ma andiamo a piedi ad Dogs
poi dove avevo fatto la prova con la
scopa vi ricordate ricordate
andiamo a prendere una birra
cita nord di Hogwarts
tutto il giorno tutti i giorni sto gioco
innaffiatoio a caso
anche se suppongo Non si possa davvero
definirla opzionale quando è tua madre a
sceglierla per te vabbè
volevo beccarlo con la Vabbè
l'incantesimo base Che cos'è ma in
questo periodo base cioè tu puoi fare
Harry Potter Scusatemi questo non me lo
ricordo
bene
senza che sia tipo che ne so
Expelliarmus
nell'equipaggiamento primo ho trovato
qualcosa che non equipaggiato Eh che era
tipo un Nokia occhiali erano accessori
per il viso Eccolo qua
santo Dio Che schifo però mi danno un
sacco di attacco perché ho avuto culo Ho
trovato un pezzo raro di nuovo questi
questi non posso fare Vabbè me li tengo
solo per goliardia Voglio vedere cosa
succede nei biblioteca succede durante i
filmati Scusatemi lo voglio vedere
Posso cuocere le mosche Ah sono queste
che mi danno le opzioni rigenerative ok
Eh no stavo quindi dicendo io avendo la
Delux Edition dovrei avere una
cavalcatura c'è qualcosa dovrei avere
comunque dei vestiti un pezzo forza che
mi segue
provenienti dalla foresta proibita
Chissà se qualcosa li ha spaventati mi
era giunta voce che avevano avvistato
degli ippogrifi nei paraggi C1 può
andare in giro e farsi le missioni come
voli per andare nella foresta pluviale e
fare quello che voglio e finissimo
fighissimo io posso vedere i test estral
Ah Scusatemi Tra l'altro Vi volevo dire
nel primo episodio
non quando ho detto che quando è morto
il personaggio all'inizio che si sono
materializzati di destra oltre a chi te
l'ha estratto li puoi vedere solo se nel
mondo magico vedi qualcuno Mori morire
oltre il crinale dopo quella rovina
dove Scusate se potessi passerei tutto
il mio tempo a esplorare
ha detto che conoscevi bene la zona
Considerato che non sei qui da molto ha
detto così
Ah vedete li vedo i test drive Questi
sono i questi sono i test Ragazzi io li
vedo lei non tipo lei non li vedrà mi sa
no lo dico perché mi ha fatto piacere
che mi avete scritto nei commenti che
sono uno dei pochi che l'hanno mandato
forse l'unico che l'ha notato che ci
materializzano in testa per questo
all'inizio Lake era tutto così nuovo e
insolito
sto cominciando ad abituarmi e tu sei
sistemata bene alla fine mi manca ancora
il mio paese
Scusami è Natasha come cazzo Voglio
vedere cos'è questo
abbassava laccio potevo farlo anche da
lontano io mi dimentico che sono nel
mondo di Harry Potter ragazzi che le
cose non posso prenderle anche senza
andarci da davanti ma solo con Accio
sono stupido e abituarsi alla Magia è un
casino eh raga Cioè non è che posso
Madonna che bello guarda che mondo è uno
può andare dove vuole pazzesca sta roba
Salve sta gente che corre Comunque qua
non ho visto ancora nessuno con la scopa
Bon è il custode di Hogwarts sembra un
po' malconcio vero Salve
piacere è meglio tornare indietro
signorina on air Girate i tacchi
mi ha guardato dritto in faccia con quei
suoi occhi enormi No sono occhiali
questi però guardi
brutto peloso terrificante
Torno al castello lì sarò al sicuro
buona fortuna a voi
Povera un Demi Guys mi sa che ha fatto
troppa baldoria al villaggio
cosa serve Io sto prendendo i materiali
ragazzi che non so cosa mi servono la
minima idea non soltanto oggi
[Musica]
Lake of me tutto il resto
Grazie mille
Grazie
molto bello
Madonna quanto fatta bene Sto male e
quindi a Oliver si trova oxmi
Sicuramente augs midd troverai tutto ciò
che ti serve
Madonna ragazzi se vivessi in questo
mondo starai seduto lì tutto il tempo a
guardare quello che succede qua ha detto
che ti sono delle ricette di pozioni
delle Magi formule dei semi e una
burrobirra Certo ti piacerà il signor
olivander vedrai Voglio proprio vedere
cosa sarà in grado di fare con una
bacchetta tua dovresti avere tutto il
tempo per recuperare ciò che ti serve e
anche per esplorare un po' il villaggio
Fai pure con calma quando avrai finito
raggiungimi alla piazza di ozmid mi
troverai lì volentieri
altri luoghi di interesse che puoi
suonare Grazie alla mappa della tua
guida però va bene
Sì vabbè certo la guida pratica Madonna
quanta roba sto male olivander è di
fronte una fiera del fumo Ah la filiale
ha della famiglia olivandi quindi non è
olivander cioè si olivander ma non è
l'olivander dei film ma la famiglia
quindi da dinastia olivardare Quindi
tutti bacchettari come si dice
vi prego vi prego questo è tutto ciò di
cui ho bisogno entriamo nella mia
bacchetta Voglio la mia bacchetta però
nel prossimo episodio ragazzi per oggi
finiamo qua domani Tanto le faccio
vedere Allora ragazzi come vedete questo
non ha avuto tagli ce ne ha avuti Sì ma
veramente molto pochi questo perché sto
cercando di rendere l'esperienza più
godibile possibile cioè farvela molto
simile a quella che sto vivendo io senza
tagliare quasi niente Spero vi piaccia
voglio dire è un tipo di video diverso
dove eh A quel punto skippate voi quando
c'è qualcosa un dialogo una cinematica
un passaggio che vi interessa di meno
oppure come me ve lo giocate tutto
guardandolo da me e quindi non schivate
niente In quel caso meglio che mi
aumenta il Watch Time quindi vi
sopportate di più però vabbè anche se vi
Mettetevi sottofondo Come compagnia non
lo so fate quello che volete Però se
volete godermelo anche eh per i prossimi
episodi non farò molti cioè farò pochi
tagli pochissimi siamo Pochissima roba
quindi è quasi un Gameplay integrale
tipo questo avrei tagliato ma non lo
taglio qui ragazzi Spero che il video vi
sia piaciuto iscrivetevi al canale Ci
vediamo domani con un altro episodio di
owes Legacy e noi ci vediamo come sempre
ad un prossimo video bella ragazzi